don't mind me just freaking out a little
bit here oh my god oh my god oh my god
hi guys it's matt welcome back to my
kitchen here on tasty we've made tons of
great recipes on how to make your own
fast food at home but there's one thing
we've never been able to capture and
that is the speed and convenience of
fast food so today in order to put that
to the test i'm going to attempt to make
one of my favorite fast food burgers the
big mac in the same amount of time it
takes to have one delivered to my house
we'll see how this
goes this is the most nervous i have
been for a video because as soon as i
start i cannot stop here we go
confirming order preparing your order
you're unable to authorize your card
okay mcdonald's is preparing my order
first thing i'm gonna start with is my
special sauce i am going to add
mayonnaise my pickle
mustard
and then onion powder garlic powder
paprika and finally white pepper this
bowl is way too small you know what i'm
just gonna mix it anyways
they have assigned a driver i am so
screwed oh my freaking god okay special
sauce is done i'm going to quickly dice
up my onion
got my iceberg lettuce i'm only going to
use a quarter of a head for this i'm
just going to shred this
finally i just want to prep my bun
because it has that middle bun i just
want to trim one of the bottom pieces to
use for it
okay john has arrived i gotta get the
burner where's the burner prep my burner
as my burner is heating up i'm going to
butter my buns and i'm just using sesame
buns for this but you can really use
whatever buns you want just let these
get nice and toasty ever you're looking
at me why are you looking at me is john
on his way
[Music]
okay perfect
buns
are almost done
set those to the side all right so for
my patties i'm keeping it nice and
simple i'm just doing 80 20 lean to fat
content so i put my beef down
and i'm just gonna
smash
i'm gonna do salt on top
cracked pepper
everett how am i doing
he's still mcdonald's i could win this i
actually feel good about this looks good
and i'm going to
flip oh perfect
perfect you can see that it's a nice
golden brown i'm just going to top one
slice
with my cheese i'd say that's probably
good
we'll dash and we'll bash alrighty so i
think i'm in the clear at this point but
before i jinx myself going to start with
my bottom bun add some lettuce
some onion
a couple little
dill pickles a middle bun some of that
special sauce secret sauce it's a secret
or special sauce topped with a little
bit more lettuce a little bit more onion
top with my final piece of meat add two
more pickles special sauce on my top bun
and wabash
boom that's a homemade big mac where's
john at
i think i did that in under 15 minutes
we got two big macs and the amount of
time it takes to order one
so right off the bat mine looks pretty
good it's got a lot of vertical height
to it feels like a lot more burger and
honestly it looks like a good comparison
to the delivery one it's the moment of
truth
and it's time to try my burgers
it's good it's a big mac it's exactly
what you'd expect consistent you got the
balance of the sauce and the lettuce and
the onions the pickles so let's give the
homemade a try the homemade one is
awesome it's got the char from the
griddle i feel like mcdonald's burgers
don't always get that nice sort of
browning on them that you'd like got the
crunchy lettuce you got the fluffy bun
this is a great homemade interpretation
of it anybody want the one i took a bite
out of thank you everett thank you and
there you have it in a race against my
delivery i was able to make two big macs
and the time it takes to make and
deliver one let me know what you guys
think in the comment section below if
you guys have any other ideas or any
other delivery options you want us to
try also let me know in the comments
below and until then take care oh yes
[Music]
you